Some of you may wake up in the morning and
think; “Me think nice, me big smart, me
no need school”
And perhaps you are right.
But many of us, no matter what qualifications
we have or what work we do, often wonder;
is my brain achieving all it could achieve?
Maybe it’s as simple as doing a bit more
exercise, eating more fish and not drinking
like the world’s going to end 2 nights a
week.
But are there other factors that affect how
well your brain does its job?
Does knowledge itself make you smarter or
is it just data that you spit out randomly?
What about puzzles and games, do these help
at all after childhood or are they simply
an escape?
And how about surgeries or drugs that could
give you some kind of edge on the competition?
So watch out Steven Hawking, I’m going to
climb that IQ ladder and kick you off the
top once I find out: Can I Get Smarter?
First off let’s all discuss the idea of
intelligence, the way it’s defined and the
way it’s measured.
On a physical level, we know relatively little
about what makes one brain intelligent compared
to another.
There’s no one bit of structure or biochemistry
that we can point to and go “ah ha, there’s
the smart bit”.
Here’s what we do know; the brain is made
up of hundreds of billions of cells and different
sections are responsible for different functions
such as language, movement and… um……
memory.
Information is passed around the brain by
neurons and synapses, where neurons are electrically
excitable cells and synapses are the connections
between them.
When you are developing, these grow at an
astonishing rate; you create 1,300 neurons
and 700,000 synapses every second.
This is your DNA, rapidly coding that giant
computer brain.
Scientists actually dissected Einstein’s
brain, after he died obviously, a bit awkward
otherwise.
One of the structural differences they found
was that he had a noticeably higher ratio
of glia to neurons, with glia being a different
kind of brain cell.
This indicates that there may be some quantifiable
difference in the brains of smart people,
but we still don’t know for sure.
So for now, we focus much more on ability
tests, rather than the brain’s physical
structure, to measure intelligence.
Francis Galton was an English statistician
and the first person to attempt to develop
some kind of standardised test for gauging
a person’s intelligence.
He expected to find a correlation between
intellect and other factors such as reflexes,
muscle grip, and head size.
If this were true, I think LL Cool J would
probably be the world’s smartest man as
he’s basically a watermelon with bear paws.
In the 1940s, psychologist Raymond Cattell
laid out the idea of two main types of intelligence;
fluid and crystalized.
Fluid was the ability to react to new situations
and solve novel problems.
Crystalized intelligence involves using skills
and knowledge that you already have.
It’s not the same as memory but it will
rely on long-term memory, especially for things
like vocabulary and general knowledge.
In the following years, John L. Horn and John
B. Carroll added further elements to Cattell’s
ideas and the Cattell–Horn–Carroll theory
is the basis of most current IQ testing.
The average IQ is 100, with the huge majority
of people sitting between 70 and 130.
A score above 130 is considered gifted and
above 144 is genius level.
William James Sidis was supposed to have had
the highest IQ of all time with a possible
number of 300.
He entered Harvard for mathematics in 1910,
at just 11 years old.
Now, where does smartness come from?
This is the big Nature versus Nurture question.
If you take the child of two knuckle dragging
morons and give it to some fancypants, genius
academics, will the child grow into a specky
little brainbox or a crayon-chewing bonehead?
We used to think that the balance was more
even between the two factors but as more evidence
appears, we see that genetics is by far the
most important factor in how smart a child
can become.
Robert Plomin, working at King’s College
London, ran the Colorado Adoption Project,
which began back in 1975.
For over 30 years they tracked adopted children,
their adoptive parents and their biological
parents to see where the most influence came
from.
They also used control families, where the
kids were raised normally by their biological
parents.
In the control groups, they found a strong
correlation between the parent’s and children’s
IQs, so this could have been all nature, all
nurture or a balance of the two.
But with the adopted children there is exactly
the same correlation to their biological parents
and ZERO correlation of their intelligence
with their adoptive parents, the people who
actually raised them.
So smart adoptive parents are not able to
raise a smart adopted child if the biological
parents of that child aren’t smart to begin
with, no matter what the adoptive parents
do.
You can’t teach an old dog new tricks, or
a stupid kid how to play the piano.
What’s more, it seems that most of your
personality is also genetic, so things like
being introverted and extroverted come from
your DNA, not from your home environment.
So is nurture completely irrelevant?
No, our environment still has a big influence
on us, especially in terms of behavior, but
psychologist Judith Rich Harris believes that
we have been focusing on the wrong part of
it.
The purpose of childhood is to prepare you
to be an adult, and being an adult does not
require you to get on with your parents.
Obviously, it’s preferable, so please don’t
finish this video and go shout “I don’t
need you anymore!”
whilst your mum is making dinner, because
you won’t get any.
It’s your peers that influence your behavior
the most.
That’s why the children of immigrants will
speak like the local population, not like
Mum and Dad.
Habits like smoking and drinking are normally
picked up from peers but a disposition to
addiction is passed down genetically, which
is why parents who smoke often have children
who smoke too.
They are not copying their parents, they usually
start smoking with their peers and then the
genes kick in that makes them hopelessly addicted.
If you want to try and give your brain a boost,
you can’t mess with your genetics, so I’m
sorry to say, you’re kind of limited to
what you were given, but you can improve your
crystalized intelligence and a thing called
your working memory, which helps your fluid
intelligence to function as well as possible.
Much like the gym, the more effort you put
in, the better results you get out; so slip
your brain into some spandex and make sure
you work it out every day.
You should challenge yourself as often as
you can and try to do things the hard way,
like working out your own route on a map,
rather than just following that blue arrow
on your satnav like it’s your guardian angel.
Although, please don’t write me an angry
comment from a car park 3 miles away because
you got lost trying to buy milk.
It’s not my fault you have no sense of direction.
Novelty is an important factor too.
If you always watch the same show, sit in
the same chair and eat the same dinner, then
not only do you really need to clean your
sofa but your brain is not getting the new
inputs it needs to learn more.
Try taking a different route to school or
work, try and learn a new skill like origami
or knitting or... whatever the hell this is.
The easiest way to get novelty is by networking,
either in the real world or online.
Other people’s ideas may often be weird,
terrifying and confusing but they will enable
you to build new ones of your own.
It’s no coincidence that over the centuries,
major jumps in science and technology occur
as we improve communication.
All ideas are built off other ideas so try
to steal as many as possible from other people
and become the super villain you were destined
to be.
Finally, for those of you who find learning
a struggle, there is light at the end of the
tunnel, but that maybe because they just turned
up the voltage too high and you’re being
electrocuted.
That’s right, a study from 2013 found that
stimulating the brain with a mild electric
current, could lead to people learning five
times faster than normal, and with good retention
six months later, not just in the immediate
aftermath.
If any of you are thinking of licking the
car battery before doing your homework, don’t.
If you really think it’s a good idea to
go out of your way to electrocute your brain,
then passing that maths test is the least
of your worries, you should probably sit in
the corner and stay away from sharp objects.
I’m sorry to tell you, but
your parents were not intelligent.